let's go to the phone 617 830 4750 is
the number let's kick things off today
with our first caller from the 757 area
code caller what's your name and where
you calling from i'm ernest i'm calling
from the Virginia Beach area great
what's on your mind I thought makes a
bold i have got two topics for the
Russian hacking and gerrymandering I
would pick one because we've got 17
people holding right now so let pick
whichever is your favorite one of the
two okay well let's go the Russian
Russian hacking uh I don't quite believe
that they actually did it because when
we trace the origin back it was about
quittin claiming that the Russians act
the DNC and show how fat they treated
Bernie and if that's the case I think we
should think the Russians okay but I
don't believe it sounds like you're
saying two different things you're
saying you think it's good that if it
was the Russians that we found out about
what we learned from the DNC but you
don't believe that it was the Russians
right so I'm confused what would
convince you that it was the right
father what can happen where you would
say okay now i believe it was the
Russians ah well I've already examined
the CIA report and not impressed by it
so right but what I evidence your
evidence upon wordage on what evidence
if you were to see it would convince you
that it was the Russian I can't play
okay that's a problem because if you
can't even hypothetically imagine what
would what would convince you that it's
the Russians then you're not really open
to being influenced by facts right if
you're not even to hypothetically come
up with something I think that this is a
problem this is a problem in the
continental club houses well I object to
that because I'm an atheist but also
don't know what would hypothetically God
to me but that doesn't mean I'm close to
that issue I just means I don't know
what would do it okay so you're not
nothing you're just saying you don't
know what would do it right if Russia
came out and said that they did the
hacking would that convince you if they
were a regular source probably ok but
Julian Assange already revealed his
source and he said it was a DNC insider
ok yeah that is I did not do that I did
not see that and what I have seen is
that the intermediary between WikiLeaks
and Russia has been identified so ok
well listen I appreciate the call I
think I think we we don't agree but it's
always interesting to hear different
perspectives on this issue so thank you
so much thank you so much for the call